kommen jetzt die mikro roboter und zwar
in unsere knie das wirklich ein super
erfolg versprechen das experiment ein
koreanisches forschungsteam hat einen
mikrometer entwickelt der sich direkt zu
verletzten knorpeln steuern lässt und
diesen dann repariert dem tierversuch
gelangen das experiment mit vollem
erfolg wie realistisch ist es dass
deutsche mikro roboter schon bald auch
menschlichen knorpel wieder herstellen
tricks um science fiction die spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen das wirtschaft wirklich
ziemlich viele menschen und jeden kann
es treffen das problem mit dem knüppel
ist groß denn wenn er einmal weg ist
dann ist er halt weg und nicht mehr
einfach wieder herzustellen
in deutschland sind es pro jahr etwa
190000 knieprothesen die implantiert
werden und das zum großteil weil es
probleme mit dem gelenkknorpel gibt
knorpel bilden können nur ganz bestimmte
stammzellen die sogenannten
mesenchymalen stammzellen
forschungsteams weltweit setzen große
hoffnung darauf mit ihrer hilfe
knorpelverletzung zu behandeln diese
machen es bei arthrose schon jetzt
möglich den einsatz eines kunst gelenkes
herauszuzögern einen koreanischen
forschungsteam ist jetzt ein spannendes
experiment mit diesen stammzellen
gelungen die fachleute haben eine art
mikro roboter entwickelt und diesen in
den körper eines kaninchens geschleust
dort haben sie ihn dann zielgenau zum
verletzten kniegelenk geleitet wo die
menschlichen stammzellen sich vermehrten
und dann den kaputten knorpel
reparierten nach angaben der
wissenschaftler in bauten sich die mikro
roboter selbst nach zwei bis drei wochen
im körper der tiere ab die in der studie
als mikro roboter bezeichneten
konstrukte bestehen aus magnetischen
kügelchen die etwa 200 bis 300
mikrometer groß sind um diese
herzustellen nutzen die fachleute das
polymer p lga dieses polylactid co klöco
lied kann vom menschlichen körper sehr
leicht abgebaut werden und wird bereits
seit einiger zeit als chirurgische smart
material eingesetzt aus diesem polymer
werden beispielsweise mikropartikel und
implantate hergestellt die porösen
kugeln wurden dann mit einer schicht aus
zwei verschiedenen komponenten überzogen
zum einen mit dabei das biopolymer
chitosan zum anderen die eisen
kohlenhydrat verbindung ferrum oxid
letzteres wird beispielsweise als
wirkstoff gegen eisenmangel eingesetzt
somit bestehen die koreanischen micro
botter also aus kunststoff sauerstoff
und eisen
die einzel mikro roboter enthalten
unzählige poren und genau darin können
die menschlichen messe schmalen
stammzellen transportiert werden sie
kleben quasi ihnen den poren fest und
fingen im experiment tatsächlich an sich
unter laborbedingungen in dieser hülle
zu vermehren
in einem nährmedium entwickelten sich
die stammzellen zudem in knorpelzellen
es erfolgte ein vortest und zwar in
einem totenschein die mikro botter
wurden indessen kniegelenk eingesetzt
und mit hilfe von magneten zu der
verletzten stelle geleitet das ist echt
ziemlich genial die technik also
funktionierte so wagte das
forschungsteam das eigentliche
experiment dazu setzten die
wissenschaftler innen den lebenden
kaninchen 100 mikro roboter in den
gelenkspalt
die kügelchen waren voll beladen mit
stammzellen die zielgenaue steuerung der
kügelchen gelang mit hilfe eines
elektromagnetischen feldes das mit
spulen um das knie der tiere aufgebaut
wurde mit hilfe eines magneten wurden
dem mikro roboter dann auch an den ort
gehalten nämlich am kaninchen gelenk
ohne diese art der fixierung nämlich
bewegten sich die kügelchen mitsamt der
stammzellen von der verletzung weg durch
den einsatz des magneten aber konnten
die roboter am gelenk gehalten werden
und der einsatz der stammzellen verlief
erfolgreich sie wurden langsam von den
kügelchen abgegeben und begannen dann an
ort und stelle mit ihrer arbeit nach
einigen wochen war der knappe teilweise
nachgewachsen in der kontrollgruppe mit
den tieren die nicht behandelt wurden
war das nicht der fall
das forschungsteam aus korea werte das
als vollen erfolg so heißt es in der
studie
das bedeutet dass das mikro
robotersystem die knappere generation
durch die zufuhr von menschlichen
stammzellen verbessert hat hinzu kommt
anders als die bisher entwickelten mikro
roboter sind die des koreanischen
forschungsteams biologisch abbaubar
nach einigen wochen löste sich das
magnetische gerüst vom kugelförmigen
grundkörper und sehr viel
laut der aktuellen studie besteht also
keinerlei risiko dass sie sich im körper
ablagern und zb zu entzündungen führen
genau das ist eine grundvoraussetzung
dafür dass diese technik in zukunft auch
im klinikalltag eingesetzt werden kann
doch dafür müssen die mikro roboter
zunächst noch in weiteren tierversuchen
getestet werden
die herausforderung besteht darin so
viele zellen wie möglich an die
verletzung zu transportieren 80.000
stammzellen in vier stunden konnten die
100 kügelchen in dem aktuellen
experiment zum kaputten knorpel liefern
im vergleich zu anderen arbeiten die
diese methode der stammzellen lieferung
nutzen ist dies eine eher kleine zahl
zudem fehlt noch ein gerät mit dem die
mikro botter in großer menge in den
menschlichen körper gespritzt werden
könnten mit einer normalen kanüle würde
wohl nur eine unregelmäßige zuvor
möglich sein auch die gestaltung der
magnete wäre für den einsatz in der
klinik noch zu optimieren schließlich
sind die menschlichen gelenke deutlich
größer als die der kaninchen ein vorteil
dieser methode ist nach ansicht des
koreanischen teams aber dass sich
patientinnen nach einem solchen minimal
invasiven eingriff schneller erholen
könnten spektrum erklärt biomarker
anklicken anschauen und spektrum video
abonnieren cooler kanal ganz neu bis
dann bleibt dran